there's 84 people challenging me so
i guess everyone who's challenging me
has a 1 in 84 chance
okay good luck to bongo boy
let's play oh let's play the jalalabad
you can't spell jalalabad without bad oh
but
opponent doesn't take the the free pawn
this is just a bad opening even if white
takes it it's
it's also bad ah
this is my first jalalabad
how do i even do this i guess d6
making the pawn smile
i don't know any theory here
but i'm going to try and develop and
we'll try and justify
this positional weakness on d5
oh this is actually a bad move man this
is such an innocent developing move too
is white gonna punish me white doesn't
punish me well i had knight g5
and i would have had to play d5 and then
cry
it's such a bad opening no any good
lines against the london for black that
begin with one
d5 anymore driving to get into the slav
when playing is black but the london
gives me trouble
looking for direction slash study
material
what it got cut off
oh it was from cyrus
um i actually have a lecture on st louis
chess club
about what i recommend against london
and you can start with d5 um
if you just search for black wins
against one d4
i should also i have a leachate study
covering
recommendation too
but there's actually there are a few
lectures on the st louis chess club
channel
covering recommendations against london
i know pepe has one
pretty sure uh chesley has one too
what is i did not even subscribe to this
thing prime
oh yeah when you subscribe with prime
you basically take money out of jeff
bezos's pocket
right and then
because it takes money from the amazon
prime
membership and then puts it towards me
so i appreciate it
opbr
stopping for four months with prime
oh maybe i'll get my my pawn
t tetris peace formation
if we trade bishops yeah let's go
look at these pawns
okay man this is starting to look
jalala good
because like the main problem with this
like terrible opening is this square d5
pointy bits ponte yeah
because when you commit to c5 and e5
there's no pawn that can control the
square
until you capture here and now i'm just
controlling
most of the center squares with my pawns
so it's nice
at some point maybe i'll expand
or maybe i'll reverse delayed bond cloud
because why not
okay so i'm attacking this pawn also has
a knife
knight has a nice square um
to jump into
my internet is fine now so don't worry
about playing me next
oh good to know
thanks for being honest
yeah i guess if you're watching twitch
on data
it could eat up a lot of the the
gigabytes
or gigabytes um
um but people should be able to control
like
quality so if you want to use less data
you can
[Music]
you can watch it like low quality or
audio only
yeah so in in this previous game when i
had this formation
i had my king like on a similar square
that was nice
in that game i i had missed a fork
so in this game i'm gonna be
on constant lookout for forks
except just kidding because the queen
the queen defends e2
so let's play rook g5
or do i just take a pawn
the thing with rook g5 is that
i'm basically provoking the queen to
move to a better place
okay let's be solid super solid
yeah how many people are not watching
the stream
but just listening to the stream there's
got to be a few
[Music]
there's someone earlier said they were
watching from work and just listening
oh wow a lot of people i guess if you're
typing in chat you have to be
kind of looking in chat
or you could just be lying
or yeah how many people are watching but
not listening
that's also maybe kind of common whoa
it's wasim wassimbi triple seven
thanks for gifting subs appreciate that
yeah wasim i uh
i played i played in the blindfold simul
which is the most recent youtube video
thanks so much also look at this
i i could potentially have i have takes
takes i'll have four center pawns
but opponent might flag or not
yeah look at these center pawns
wow okay opponent wants to play this
i'll play a4
i still have to be careful here probably
gonna run with the king
okay that scared me for a moment my
queen is pinned
but i'm still defending everything the
queen defends the pawn through
some kind of x-ray vision
hmm
i don't think i mind a queen trade
i'm dreaming of like having five center
pawns
that might be difficult though
let's go after some stuff
yes i'm guaranteed to win this pawn
[Music]
i mean the whole goal is to get
the indestructible pawn cube
which should be achievable
yeah even if we trade
okay so i'm losing the this uh this a
pawn
[Music]
but that's okay because of the pawn the
pawn cube will like kind of
crawl its way
or what's not it's not crawling what do
caterpillars do are you kind of like you
compress and then decompress
wiggle yeah
it'll like wiggle its way forward
because you decompress and you compress
and then etc
and then eventually you turn into a
butterfly
contract oh but i wants to promote
hey let's go jalwala bad leads to
indestructible central pawn cube of
greatness
it's so beautiful but i better not lose
this
okay i have to play a little bit of
defense i'm also potentially losing this
pawn
uh-oh what is endgame
okay i should be fine right
wait a minute takes if i take the pawn i
lose
because here here takes takes
or do i win wait let's calculate it's
actually kind of a fun calculation
exercise
okay so it takes here here
takes takes here
and then here here here
[Music]
here here here
here queen d3 check unfortunately i'm
not winning there
like the king somehow miraculously
survives
[Music]
man i i have to i have to use the pawn
cube somehow
i should probably use my king too
so let's wiggle my way forward
this is so bizarre i'm i'm technically
up a pawn
but the pawn count doesn't really matter
yeah my rook's gonna forever be kind of
babysitting this thing
how do i do this
this is so confusing
but it's fun and that's what matters
it's so beautiful it's not every day you
get
four pawns like directly in the center
[Music]
wait how do i do this
if i move my king here the king gets
kind of in the way
oh i have an idea okay so king's gonna
lead the way
and then here if i play this first
white somehow blockades i mean that
might also be good because i play this
this this this this
but this looks more appetizing
here we go
it's so beautiful i probably could have
queened
i should probably queen
okay so no more i guess no more oh wait
what does this move
okay good thing i have this move
there we go what a game
i'll take here
uh this is kind of a feel-good end game
i don't know if i was always winning
yeah there's no there's no reason to
play this i should have queen right away
but okay that was fun uh
that was my first jalalabad too wow what
a jalalabad
opponent played solidly so white missed
an opportunity in this position
to to really punish me
because in order to not lose this pawn i
either have to do this or this
which both lose material
yeah man i'll probably have to play the
jalalabad more often
especially if it leads to positions like
this
i think it's winning so white should
play king e2 here
i think this would have been a bit more
annoying
okay stafford says i'm up eight pawns
but king here it's weird because
my rook's a bit stuck
i what do i do here
oh i can probably just advance yeah i
would just wiggle my way up
like d3 king here and then here
sacrificing upon
but then i become a butterfly
and then this doesn't do anything
because
wait
oh yeah i can do this this this this
and then probably this and then i'll
just move here next and queen
and white can't really stop inevitable
okay that was fun hello to youtube
yeah it was kind of that was a long game
but uh
had some uh some excitement uh if you're
watching on youtube
drop a like and a comment and smash the
subscribe button
and say hi to twitchchat and i'll see
you in the future